we've got some apples here and we've got
some oranges and what i want to think
about is what is the ratio
what is the ratio
of
apples
of apples
to oranges
two oranges
and to clarify what we're even talking
about a ratio is giving us the
relationship between quantities of two
different things so there's a couple of
ways that we can specify this we can
literally count the number of apples one
two three four five six so we have six
apples
and we could say the ratio is going to
be six two
six
two and then how many oranges do we have
one two three four five six seven eight
nine it is six to nine ratio of apples
to oranges is six to nine and you could
use different notation you could also
write it this way
you would still read it as the ratio is
being 6 2
but we don't have to just satisfy us
with this because one way to think about
ratios if especially we're thinking
about apples to oranges is how many
apples do we have for a certain number
of oranges and when you think about it
that way both six and nine are divisible
by three so if you divide six and nine
both by three six divided by three is
two
six divided by three is two and nine
divided by three is three so we could
also say that the ratio of apples to
oranges is two to three or if we want to
use this notation
2 2 3. now does that make sense
well look we divided each of these
groups into 3 so one way to think about
it so if you divide
if you divide this whole total into
three groups so one group
one group
two groups
and three equal groups
we see that in each of those groups for
every two apples for every two apples we
have three oranges for two apples we
have three oranges so once again the
ratio of apples to oranges for every two
apples we have three oranges but we
could think about things the other way
around as well we could also think about
what is the ratio
ratio of oranges to apples oranges
to apples and here we would essentially
switch the numbers
the ratio of oranges
to
apples notice up here we said apples to
oranges which is six to nine or two to
three which is an equivalent ratio and
here we're gonna say the ratio of
oranges to apples so we've swapped these
two and so we're going to swap the
numbers here we have nine oranges for
every six apples so we could say the
ratio is going to be 9
6.
the ratio is 9 to 6 or an equivalent
ratio for every 3 oranges so we're going
to divide this by 3 so for every 3
oranges
we are going to have
two apples
we are going to have two apples so
notice this is just exactly what we had
up here but when we had apples to
oranges it was six to nine six apples
for every nine oranges and now in its
oranges to apples we say it's nine to
six nine oranges for every six apples
or we could say for every three oranges
we have exactly two apples